voici la caricature en question le
président trempe aveugle guidés par un
chien qui est benyamin nétanyahou le
caricaturiste n'en est pas à sa première
controverse
la capsule est excellent c'est aller
bien
c'est très drôle c'est netanyahu en
quarts en chine yang inpi gueule qui
tient parole
serge chapleau caricaturiste à la presse
est étonné de la réaction que ce dessin
a provoqué je ne comprends pas du tout
la crise vient des cinq hommes se
caricature cessera en cd jean jacques
goldstyn caricaturiste au journal the
gazette a des réserves
je trouve que la kippa les tant d'années
c'est peut-être un peu trop sinon il
faut rajouter des bébés dans l'est dans
les poches ou d'argent qui sort voilà ce
qu'il aurait dessiné le char d'assaut
pour présenter peut-être le côté un peu
en mairie soit peut-être que ce sera
peut-être plus pensée pour ces deux
caricaturistes
il faut savoir à quel public on
s'adresse les sensibilités ne sont pas
les mêmes
au canada de lille mais cela ne veut
juste dessiné la reine avec une feuille
d'érable qui donc il ya eu des plaintes
des plaintes on ne fait pas touché à la
cheville ou ce qu'il ya autour de la loi
21 les engueulades et sur leur nuage on
a les deux patrons qui sont là avec leur
sillage
bof et puis d'une canne c'est la gagne
et cette caricature a été publiée par
caen à oui mais ils m'ont demandé
d'enlever à la mais ce n'est pas qu'un
problème de censure ou d'auto censure
selon cet analyste des médias
ça va beaucoup plus loin on est aussi
dans une époque où les lobs et joue un
rôle majeur pour essayer d'influencer
aussi l'opinion publique et en passant
par parler les grands les grands médias
tous les médias sont menacées de
disparaître selon alain saulnier ils
sont vulnérables
alors on joue de prudence l'expression
qu'on utilise quand on joue au poker et
usé toujours jay kay ta part au départ
on a parfois trop peur aussi
et ça fait en sorte que plus on recule
plus nos limites vont aussi reculé par
contre la mondialisation peut aussi
avoir du bon celui-ci canton le cas une
refuse complètement le yéti vu partout
lequel katiola ce qui est fait comme ça
jamil va voler contre issy catherine
kovacs radio canada montréal